hey everyone
Jessica Jones is finally coming back two
and a half years later no big deal hey
i'm leanna galera I'm master Allison and
we are here to catch you up on
everything you probably forgot from
season one of Jessica Jones has been two
and a half years plus we're gonna be
previewing season two and giving you our
predictions cuz we have quite a few yes
definitely we're also gonna be breaking
down our double shots and hangovers of
season one so you don't want to miss
that
so before you descend into that deep
dark Netflix binge let's talk about our
favorite Marvel superhero Jessica Jones
let's kick things off with the obvious
ash who is Jessica Jones she she is a
private investigator she runs alias
investigations by her own company oh
yeah besides you know being a
businesswoman she's more than that she's
gifted she is gifted she has superhuman
strength enhanced speed enhanced
durability and to kick it all off she
can kind of fly she can kind of fly okay
it's more like jumping at long distances
she doesn't always stick the landing but
it's pretty interesting but sometimes
they fly and they're just like oh she's
flying and we don't see it yeah but it's
cool I like it I like it too so keeps
you grounded in the world but basically
when we meet jessica jones in season 1
she's dealing with a little bit of PTSD
she has been through a lot and we'll be
getting into that in just a little bit
and she copes with that with a lot and a
lot and lots and lots of lots of alcohol
Cheers hmm that's Jessica Jones but
let's talk a little bit about how she
got her abilities because this was a
little bit of a mystery in season 1 we
were able to piece together that Jessica
was involved in a car crash when she was
a teenager while she was on a family
road trip right and we don't exactly
know how she got her actual abilities
and a little fun fact is in the comics
they get into a car accident with this
this chemical truck yeah like a military
come yeah yeah and the chemicals then
give her superpowers but it's alluding
to in the show that she gets her powers
via experiments from this IgH lab which
we don't fully know a lot about yet and
they're gonna explore a lot of that in
season two I believe but it's still kind
of coming together exactly how she got
her powers but we know it's kind of
based in this
definitely and it's actually really
traumatic because although she does have
these superhuman abilities it came at
the cost of losing her entire family yes
all right now that we've talked a little
bit about how Jessica got her powers
let's talk about the people in her world
there were a lot of characters that we
met in season one of Jessica Jones so
we're breaking it down to the six you
need to remember before tuning in to
season two first up my favorite slash
least favorite yes kill Graham killgrave
oh man David Tennant was the best
villain tell us about kilgrave oh my
gosh so he is the most terrifying
villain that I've ever seen he you know
he has these mind-control abilities
where he can get people to do pretty
much whatever he wants but the scariest
part is he you know can control Jessica
and it's it's terrifying
he held her captive for several months
he basically forced her to have sex with
him yes the entire time that they were
together he claims that they were in
love but that was not at all it was
completely against her will no it's it's
this such it's such a kind of triggering
abusive relationship unfold and you know
I believe it's around SEPA sewed seven
where she says you raped me and it's
it's very terrifying and it's rooted in
this real thing that's I kind of think
that is going on right now that's the
conversation that's going on so it's it
was a really triggering thing to watch
but it was it was very you know scary
and real it was definitely I think the
most haunting aspect of this show that
someone could control your mind force
you to do whatever they wanted to right
and you had no ability to say no and she
thinks he's she's escaped for him she
thinks he's dead and then he kind of
comes around and starts picking off
these people around her adaptil treating
himself back into her life and then she
meets Luke Cage Jessica Jones and Luke
Cage the love story of our time ladies
and gentlemen near endgame they are
endgame in my opinion so Luke Cage this
was actually our first introduction to
this fellow defender of Jessica they
eventually joined forces together to
save New York City but here's what we
learned about Luke Cage in season one
that he too has superhuman strength and
unbreakable skin it also led to some
pretty intense sex scenes
yes it did god I love this show but
it was really interesting to see that at
the dynamic between Jessica Jones and
Luke Cage because they had a hidden
connection that we discovered luke
cage's wife Reva Connors was murdered he
thought that it was by a random bus
accident but in reality Jessica Jones
murdered Reva take care of that
she eventually told him the shocking
revelation and kilgrave then took
advantage of the fact that Luke Cage was
upset with Jessica controlled his mind
and eventually we saw this epic showdown
between Luke Cage and Jessica Jones both
of their powers in full strength and it
only ended when Jessica shot him
point-blank in the face with a shotgun
right and because he has impenetrable
skin it didn't actually hurt him but it
did internally yeah I had this like
blunt-force trama
effects but he wasn't actually yes shot
and of course we have to talk about
Trish Walker Jessica Jones this BFF
tonight you're Trish and you're just
yeah it's that's Ian casting so Trish
rocker of course is a former model and
child star known best for playing Patsy
on the hit TV show Trish actually had a
really tumultuous relationship with her
mother Doris Dorothy she was extremely
abusive and that led Trish to becoming
addicted to pretty much anything and
everything her mom essentially just
pulled a PR stunt and adopted Jessica
Jones yes that does happen that actually
happens just like this will be good for
us this will be good for us let's adopt
this your random schoolmate
I do not like her I mean we're not
supposed to but I really just don't like
I really cannot stand Dorothy but the
great thing about it was that although
it was a bizarre situation as to how
Jessica and Trish came into each other's
lives
they eventually grew to love each other
and Trish is really the only person in
Jessica's life that she would do
anything for and then Trish kind of
becomes a sidekick for Jessica
throughout the season maybe a little
more beside her I think Trish is a lot
more powerful than just a sidekick yeah
I mean but they've been really alluding
to the fact that they are really gonna
team up in season 2 Jerry hogarth one of
the more polarizing characters of season
one you know she's a top-notch lawyer in
New York City and she often recruited
Jessica as a private investigator for
her firm to help out with her cases
hogarth ended up becoming really
instrumental in season 1 but she's
getting a divorce she she was getting a
divorce she had an affair it seemed like
there was a lot of do anything to get
this divorce
anything anything but she she was really
instrumental in season one because she
was representing this woman named hope
yes who under kilgrave's mind-controlled
murdered who two parents and Jessica was
really determined to get Hope cleared of
this murder but how on earth do you
justify that somebody told you to murder
your parents yeah you can't just go
around throwing out mind control
whatever on being like sure okay yeah
yeah that's totally believable no I've
got like bad lawyer but so hogarth
was it important in season one we're
still not the biggest fans of her but
she will be returning I just she just
made a lot of bad decisions based on her
own emotions I wasn't caring about
anybody else I got a lot of people in a
lot of pain and killed him stuff
essentially ash and I are too windy
[Laughter]
welcome
I loved Malcolm he went through such an
arc throughout that's like he started
off as you know this drug-addicted kind
of junkie neighbor and then he went
turned into a villain where he's taking
pictures of Jessica working under
kilgrave and then he gets clean and kind
of becomes her social worker friend with
a conscious oh yeah I loved him yeah I
think except whenever he was with Robin
because I didn't want to talk about
Robin we're gonna skip right over Robin
she drove me nuts but for all the fans
who forgot about Robin like I did she
was the redhead neighbor who had the
twin brother who was always up in
everyone's business
I just didn't know why Robin next bye oh
god speaking of someone that we did not
like will Simpson oh my god
all right guys as you'll remember will
Simpson was the police officer who was
ordered by kilgrave to attack and kill
Trish yes
he failed yes and then somehow Trish and
will started they bonded they had this
moment where they're talking through a
door and then they're like you know what
we should be we shopping sex with each
other yes and so they started hooking up
and then I'm into it for like a minute
yes but then he inserted himself he
found out about kilgrave and he had this
personal vendetta like how dare someone
control my mind I'm going to kill him
yes he did not think that Jessica was
doing enough and so he took matters into
his own hand went back to this old
military program that he
was a part of which ash can speak to the
Marvel of it all yes
so he's based off this comic comic book
supervillain guy named nuke who
basically was like this Soviet War vet
who took these three pills red white and
blue yeah red one amped you up and the
blue one calmed you down and white even
Jew out yes and so it was like kind of a
version of this but because we'll just
kept popping the red one yeah and turned
into this intense man I just did not get
what his point was but I guess it was to
create roadblocks for Jess from getting
killed great it could have been possibly
you know it could be possibly setting up
something for season two of him being
the big bad or whatever but I think you
either go full nuke yep or you get rid
of him yep because he's right in the
middle right now and it's not it's not
working yeah give us the red pill or the
blue pill we don't want the white film
exactly we've pretty much recapped all
of season 1 through these character
character descriptions but let's just
give you the nitty-gritty of it all so
if we were to talk about season 1 in a
nutshell in a wit and it whiskey glass
we start off
Jessica's suffering from PTSD from
everything that kilgrave did to her
because he's a monster kilgrave made her
kill Reva Connors yes and then because
of that murder it broke the spell that
kilgrave had over Jessica she walked
away from him after he yelled get back
here Jessica and then and then he got
hit by a bus
so Jessica thought he was dead did she
bother to go back and check no she just
wanted to get the hell out of there
Marvel you always check you first yeah
if they're not decapitated and burned
they're still alive they're still alive
so the game of thrones room so kilgrave
comes back and he is even more obsessed
with getting Jessica to love him yes he
buys her childhood home he completely
recreates her bedroom it's really making
her sent him selfies yes but what
Jessica doesn't realize is that
killgrave knows that he can no longer
control Jessica Jones it took her a
little bit longer to figure it out
yeah she's got a lot of mind but
eventually through a lot of
back-and-forth kilgrave's parents came
back into the play they eventually got
murdered it was very dramatic
Jessica cornered
grave and it came down to this final
showdown yes on the docks yes where they
have this they have this kind of bad
plan that ends up working out yeah
because that's what happens sometimes
but they they send in Trish disguised as
Jessica listening to loud music so that
kilgrave can't shout any commands at her
and then he's like do it there oh come
on it's Patsy Patsy Patsy and so he
realizes it and then jessica jones is
like really far away from where from him
so it I don't know what the plan was
exactly and then she just kind of flies
over and then they start fighting and
then he's like I'm gonna take Trish and
be with her so he's basically threatens
the one thing that Jessica actually
cares about in life our girl Trish
that's our girl Trish and then when it
really comes down to it Jessica reveals
that kilgrave's still does not have the
mind-control abilities and she snaps his
neck that's such a good moment this is
like smoke throne-room stuff where he's
like she's like I love you talking to
Trish snaps his neck
by that was pretty much the end of
season one except for of course the
legalese of it all they tried to book
Jessica for kilgrave's murder but
Hogarth conveniently got her off see she
was important after all yeah I think
she's like fine I just I didn't like her
decision she's a good friend to have in
your corner Jessica did not have a
choice she was compelled against her
will and there we go
that was the traumatic season whoo let's
go into the double shots and hangovers
cuz I'm really excited about this all
right guys are double shots and
hangovers so basically a double shot are
the things that we loved we want Maura
we would just reach them all night and
our hangover is the self explanatory you
don't want one my double shots of season
one was learning more and more about
Jessica's past and really piecing this
together I loved the way that they
structured this season we kind of were
dropped into her world and through a
series of flashbacks and weh-weh
flashbacks we got to know this character
we got little pieces and it was up to
the audience to put them together to
figure out how she got her powers what
happened with her and killgrave and I
felt like an investigator myself so I
found that really fun oh that's so cute
I also like in season two they were
alluding to we're gonna keep going back
to this accent so it's yellow unfolding
mine is definitely gonna be kilgrave I
think he is one of the best if not the
best villain in Marvel on screen in
terms of the movies and the TV shows
because for the most part in the Marvel
Universe as much as I love it you have
these villains that just want to
dominate the world and they just want
the Avengers and the defenders and the
whatever is dead yeah
for whatever reason just to dominate
everything ultimate power giant chaotic
situation I hurt myself saying that but
what kilgrave wants is is such a on a
smaller scale and that's why villains
like kill monger and vulture and and
killgrave work is because they're on the
smaller scale real thing that is very
creepy and real and triggering and that
is what killer doesn't he just wants to
be with Jessica and Sebastian that's the
terrifying thing of it all is he's not
creating enough waves for it to cause a
nationwide panic so that everyone knows
about it know what he does is very
selfish and very sadistic I also think
he has some of the creepiest moments
I've ever seen when
he's you know in the cafe and yells
everybody be quiet or when they want
when Jessica walks out in the police
precinct and everyone holding it's so
scary
yeah in 30 seconds you'll realize this
was a hilarious joke and you'll let
jessica jones leave as far as hangover
as the moments that we really did not
want to see I gotta say will Simpson
dude your entire storyline really
bothered me but I just found his entire
military creepy background just
unnecessary I understand that it was to
give us answers as to Jessica's IgH link
but I just felt like there was another
way to go about it I feel like they were
trying to bring in the character of nuke
but they were trying to make him like a
little too rooted in reality and they're
like well he needs to be like a police
officer for I don't know it didn't work
for me it didn't land for me either
mine is definitely gonna be like Hogarth
divorce but I kind of mentioned all of
this earlier like I don't mind that
you're going through a divorce like go
through your thing I just felt like it
was used to like just to make the worst
decisions and she got a lot of people
killed and I just really she drove me
nuts the one good thing about the
hogarth divorce though was the thousand
cut oh that was a horror movie kilgrave
ordered 1z to kill her ex by death of a
thousand cuts that was so creepy and so
terrifying and shot brilliantly there
there are moments in this in the show
that are scarier than any slasher film
I've ever seen as we enter season two
you know this is going to be fresh off
of the defenders and for those of you
because I know a lot of fans who came in
to Jessica Jones didn't necessarily end
up watching Luke Cage or daredevil or
iron fist or defenders truthfully I do
not blame you it was a long journey and
I would not say that the defenders
necessarily was a good payoff for the
Jessica Jones fans mm-hmm she was the
best part of it but there was no
character development for her right so
if you're worried you don't have to have
watch the defenders just know that it
takes place after that and they save the
city even 200
so they've teased a lot of things like
we don't know what ton about what we're
getting because it's Marvel and they
like to just keep it all Sivir and then
drop it yes follow once on Netflix but
we do know we're getting a lot more of
Jessica Jones origins story and possibly
how exactly she got those powers what
happened in that
each lab experimentation but what I'm
really excited about is the possibility
that we're gonna get Trish s help at I
am so pumped for this because Hellcat is
a character that I as a non Marvel comic
book fan did not know much about and she
sounds incredibly badass yes so she
basically is you know she's like this
martial arts expert which we saw Trish
using Krav Maga season 1 she definitely
has that down but how cut also has some
some abilities she's got you should
could make forcefield she's got a little
bit of psychic ability are they gonna
get that are they gonna explore that is
she gonna get that somehow when they go
into these this IgH lab thing or maybe
they they don't maybe she just is like
this kick-ass lady and takes on the
moniker of Hellcat because we did see
that she wanted Jessica Jones to become
a superhero because she she brought the
jewel costume so maybe maybe Trish is
just really kick-ass and then decides
that she wants to also be a superior
because they say she says Jessica Jones
needs a psychic but we do know that in
season two kilgrave will be returning in
some capacity yeah I have to wonder
about this cuz they do show him you know
kind of class there have been photos
that have been released of David Tennant
back in season two we have no idea as to
what capacity that's gonna be I
personally think it's going to be some
kind of traumatic visions at ESD yeah I
mean I think it's gonna I think possibly
it'll probably be like the Dexter's dad
thing the whole time where he kind of
keeps showing up so letting her accept
yeah kind of haunting her throughout the
show and maybe possibly keep coming back
in that form I don't know if he's alive
I mean she's not this next but it is cuz
this time we actually saw her kill him
we saw this we saw it she and but it's
Marvel so you never know what if he
isn't back this makes me wonder who the
villain is of season 2 because we don't
really know we really don't know it I
don't know how you top killgrave I
really don't know how you top kill great
but we're gonna be there every step of
the way trying to figure out and then we
have this other character Price Chang I
believe his name is and yams in and he's
like her rival and wants to buy her
agency and but I don't know this guy is
not a character that we've seen in the
comics no so it could go throughout the
whole show and at the end he's like
I'm Tony Stark obviously it's not but
like he could like maybe be like they
used to call me another name and then
like drop some superhero or villain name
or whatever exactly as of now he's no
one we've met before
all I know is that I'm so excited
because I feel like Jessica Jones is the
most rooted in normal life agreed
her characters are not like Iron Fist
where they were acquired by some monks
up in a mountain it seems to be a lot
more rooted into normal things we will
be getting I can reveal that we will be
getting to meet a few more gifted
characters but they're also not
necessarily gonna be something that
would be too far-fetched for any Jessica
Jones fan to process that's the great
thing about it and I think it's worth
mentioning too
this season drops on Women's Day and
every single episode is directed by a
woman yes it is and I think that is the
coolest thing that is so awesome and so
cool and so important I'm very excited
about that and I want to say I think
this is the very first TV series to have
an entire season of shows directed
solely by women which is so
revolutionary absolutely just Joe's
making us so proud eking us so proud so
proud of women still ladies night making
a devil and that does it
that's everything that you guys needed
to remember from season one plus a
little taste of season two oh my gosh we
are gonna be breaking down and recapping
everything about season two so you guys
got to keep checking back with us we are
gonna be telling you all of our favorite
double shots and hangovers tell you what
we didn't like we're not afraid exactly
so once you guys come back up for air
after your Netflix binge sesh come back
and check with us
we're gonna be chatting about all of our
favorite Jessica Jones minutes on
Twitter
yeah night us yeah tweet us like comment
subscribe all that great stuff and we'll
see you next time bye guys